yeah hello and welcome to this video
video playing saggy sleep och
Grandmaster sleep och what is he doing
age four Wow going into early punishment
mode so um probably not a bad move by
the way this insertion is probably not
bad for white hmm
so what am I doing here one thing that
is a little bit what's happening is I
have Bishop g4 that is not such an easy
move to get in without the H pawn moves
quite often times place h3 to prevent it
or there are tactics like Bishop f7 now
that we should be protecting so Bishop
f7 doesn't work
hmm okay yeah it's a double attack but I
did not take into account at all hmm
that could be ugly quite ugly
I own this g5
not good
can just about avoid the loss of a piece
yeah I think just about check it's still
pretty bad for us
to take f3c 3 and then d5 pretty awful
pretty awful
Jim what is he thinking about him
yo so now I cannot take on d5 quite
clearly and young problem just castle I
mean my development is not so bad
especially the bishop on g7 is strong
makes it difficult for him to easily
develop his bishop on c1 check okay so
mm-hmm what now like 85 opening
everything up
but if 6a check your form yeah maybe my
D pawn isn't exactly great
yeah but this is not so bad it's not pre
move I have some ideas now take on f3
take on h4 sometimes take on f3 94 and
96 this is the direct idea that's a
strange move why do why I love that okay
[Music]
don't don't understand anything here M
96 or like the form I can also take h4 I
don't know that h4 looks very much
decentralizing
the sea might develop the bishop and one
dad taking too long here for this I can
not not be certified
come on I think thinking for a minute in
this bloody position and I have tons of
good moves and then I blunder Bishop g5
and sometimes I really wonder what's
wrong with me and he doesn't play it
I'll go okay crazy
in this position like everything was
good like every single move was good and
I had spend a minute and then her
blunder and he doesn't doesn't take it
him oh my
hmm yeah what to do I think taking this
is better I'm ready to enter with the
rook on the second ring okay take it
Jack being saved b6 is a good safe
square and rooks it to comes next
could have taken f3 come on play good
moves and now he has Bishop f6 for God's
sake with with with threats um come on
I'm warning I really don't want to lose
this game and he played such rubbish
sorry yeah I mean just rook takes f3 was
easy probably easy
[Music]
and don't see a move now for white a
good one rook takes g2 it's pretty
severe threat check check check
and this isn't hanging yeah I didn't see
that I thought it was hanging check it
took me one
check check check check white for fits
on time
okay so mu tough one and a couple of
misses there for both sides but Wow okay
so the opening really went completely
wrong
[Music]
yeah so that was very tricky King f8
computer chess at its best King f8 equal
no that move is impossible for me and
now d5 was good that cannot be bad you
know
and this is actually so here I was
thinking I take this yes this this and I
play with two knights against two
bishops but White has no pawn structure
[Music]
engine doesn't feel like black is worse
maybe that's true
I mean I'm also quite good in terms of
development here and here I have some
compensation for the porneia the engine
gives equal it gets totally rillette now
Bishop d3 is an extremely strange move
what does that do and now here and yeah
I'm spoiled early I have tons of good
looking moves and of all of them I
played this which just blunders this
move which it doesn't play I mean it's
such a such a [ __ ] I mean sometimes and
after like one minute gem and what
exactly is the move that you will play
of course Bishop g5 okay it didn't do it
and now no black is just fine yeah
and now here please here here please
take on f3 yeah why not take here cover
this and have two pawns up for
absolutely nothing
instead this and it gets somewhat murky
again yeah I'm not mated but this is
more luck than anything and okay it was
raining at the seams the whole time but
check check J took me boil until I
spotted - yeah okay you never clear a
wins but one one is one is enough yeah
this is amazing I you think for one
minute and then I take on h4 and okay
guys thanks for watching